hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to inscription so when
i say i'm back hey buddy i'm not really
back just yet so hold on hold on hold on
because there is secrets
all around us
three six one two three six one two
i don't wanna solve it this way i was
trying to try to brute force it but that
doesn't make any sense what is the deal
with all of you i know that's a puzzle
but i don't know of any place to put
that in three six one two or six one two
three but i think it's three six one two
what could it possibly be
uh whatever let's try to play a bit see
if anything changes
what is that oh beehive that's not
really helpful
i have flying squirrels now
and that's great we love that why do we
love that i don't know i don't know
oh there's something else here
there's something else here there's
something hidden in the darkness and i'm
gonna find it i'm gonna find it because
i got flying squirrels
i might just die you know i'm not doing
too good on this opening here so i think
i might just die
gotta be another clue that it gives me
from death i don't think that being
alive is where i'm gonna get my best
options you know what i mean
oh oh
god damn it i forgot i have three lives
let's try to get the kingfisher thing
before we give up completely come on
king oh there it is
hell yeah well that was easy
all right kingfisher
we got it let's see if we can actually
do it
aquatic squirrels
we got flying squirrels now we got
swimming squirrels
all right let's see if we can do the
kingfisher it was kingfisher on the
left it was on the left squirrel was on
the right kingfisher was on the left
yes
all right i'm gonna pop my emergency
squirrel for this and squirrel i do
believe if i'm wrong about this
make me
i knew it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
corpse maggot not really what i was
going for but the stone will die and
this will be okay
man it's really hard this game's hard
without all my overpowered cards
salutations yeah salitations
[Music]
okay i've won that that's good i don't
have how would anybody have pelts this
early i don't even understand what did i
get what is that
what is that a glass
fly
what is this
you don't like squirrels what's wrong
what
very well what my wait a minute hold on
the bar hold the phone i like squirrels
don't get me i like squirrels what did
you just do what did you do
what did you do
what did you do i just want to know what
you dude
what did you dude
did you replace my squirrels with flies
making them like a bug class and
therefore the squirrel totem won't apply
to them is that what you just did
because that would suck that would
really suck that would suck a lot
i'll put this on the market card i guess
super powered marquee move
great
[Music]
a b
what the hell is there a b in my
oh that's the squirrels now are bees
and they are insects
i hate that is that forever now god damn
you so hard i didn't want that
well this sucks
huh bees hobbies great bees
i mean it is it is nice because now my
baseline thing does do flying and i
could always get the bug thing but it's
also not why i'm here playing this round
this round is about exploration this
round is about finding what the hell is
going on here what are these things
what's with the hammer right it's about
that
not about what this is all about
yay i guess
so now i need the oh
look at that look at that that would be
great but i have to get the bug one so
all my bees can swim as well as fly
which is good i guess but i need to kill
the bees
to be able to do anything
maybe it won't even give me the squirrel
totem first next time because
obviously
that wouldn't need it i'm just gonna go
ahead and die because
i think that there's
there's gotta be something in the
restarts that's gonna give me a clue it
said something about the knife there was
something about the knife in the last
one wait wait wait wait hold on let me
use the knife
if he wasn't the knife like thing maybe
it was in the rule about the knife i
should have checked that before i used
my knife because now i can't use
anything whatever is fine
i don't know why i'm trying i'm supposed
to die
i apologize
wait i'm trying to die god i keep trying
to play i'm trying to die
maybe maybe i can check the rule book
after this one wait let me actually
let me actually win
or try to win anyway
but oh all my bugs have swimming i
forgot about that
well that is andy
[Music]
huh
it was it or
it was something in like the box of
eyeballs maybe
maybe that was going to be able to
tell me what that was
there's something going on here there's
something going on
where's the knife rule
maybe there's something in the entry
about knives
you will place a weight on the scales
the whoa
oh wow
whoa find salvation in cuckoo clock i
knew
i knew it happy with that one yes i am
this eye kind of buzzes you know
okay
ah
i was actually gonna be pretty if i had
done my brute force which i was doing
here
i would have been
pretty close
it would not have taken me that long
hello
take the film roll before he sees it
now
what are you doing over there turn to
face me
what are you up to over there
interesting
and i don't like these goops
i don't like the goops
keep sealed
could it be you have the masters uh you
have the master's eye does this mean the
master can see me
magnificus can you see me
can you free me interesting
very
interesting okay
i almost played to lose there which
would not have been a good idea okay
since i'm going bug strat i would just
go for bugs that's my best bet here i
think i think group of survivors are
starving
okay
whoa what the hell happened to you if
you must
okay i'm not gonna i'm not gonna push my
luck with this one because i wanna hear
what this one has to say i can't even
risk it not being there so i think i
have to go and beat this one now i
wasn't really uh focused on that so uh i
wasn't really prepared for it but
uh thank you how has it been
it has been quite bad i'm trapped in the
body of a stoke
in the paper of a card
i see that
and i of course set up a way to reset
once more
go on
our player friend here they already hold
the key
so i have to win this i literally have
to win this why do you have bees so why
do you have bees
well i'm supposed to be the one to have
bees you don't get that bees i get bees
[Music]
here we are
yes here we are
a lot of bees
you're a bad play
[Music]
okay so i need to do literally whatever
it takes to win now which is not what i
was prepared for but i'm so good at this
game that nothing could phase me and i'm
always gonna be
beehive that doesn't really help me a
lot because you're aquatic and that is
not exactly what i'm going for but you
know it is what it is i could get a wolf
and get the double wolf again i do like
the wolves they are good cards but uh
sometimes in beehive why not go with the
whole insect route that seems to be what
i'm doing anyway
why not
uh
let's make the beehive stronger then
i still don't know if they actually even
eat the thing i just don't want to push
it
all right i need to get another totem
let's go for the totem fight
stinky
ah that's not good
he took the film
is that correct
my plan nears its moment of truth
but you must defeat him first
okay
all right i'll do my best don't you
worry about a thing let me worry about a
thing
sure wish i could go in my deck and hunt
for guards that'd be delightful
yes i'm sure
oh wait i could have put the bullfrog
there oh
that's fine
it's fine
oh you're stinky god damn it i'm stupid
ah i am dumb
i did do it bad i forgot about the stink
ow
great
getting there
slow and steady i guess
oh this is a wind
good
okay good
can't deal with any losses right now
gotta win
and i gotta get something good for these
bugs
better than swimming
okay mantis that's another bug let's go
mantis
let's get bugs let's go bugs
i think we're doing bugs i think we're
doing bugs
i think bugs is what's happening
oh bugs bugs bugs baby bugs
yes
infinite bugs i love that so much for me
i love that so much for me i love that i
love that for me
aquatic bugs huh that's why i used to
have that
until i found a better strategy
yeah
yeah oh yeah
oh yeah now if only i had
cards worth doing that for
uh
let's keep you right there
total miss play you're a total miss play
miss play my ass
ant versus frog
doesn't seem like a total miss play now
does it
excellent
pretty uh not a miss play huh [ __ ]
all right give me bug
bug it is
i'll take that
i don't know if i have two of the same
card that's that's what i don't think i
have
nope i don't no duplicates take one of
ours
oh
[Music]
oh
oh interesting i'll go for the ant
not that i want a super powerful double
amp but more ants is good
now i got two ants and an ant queen
that's good
that's good
no smoke
okay you ass bag you ass wretched ass
bag with your monkey boots and your
unnatural face look at that stupid face
bring fish yeah i bring fish no i bring
bug
better than fish bug
an angler
mind is hook play a squirrel or
something when he ain't i know what
thanks this would have done
would have helped me a long time ago
look at all these bugs okay first off
b time well you guys aren't going to hit
each other so it don't really matter but
b
you're going to hit twice
you guys
greater smoke's gonna protect against
that well no it's not not gonna protect
against anything i could have stunk him
up i guess i don't have the bones for it
all right
wow look at this
kind of helps when the bees do the
damage
oh no you don't
interesting i do have to be careful
because then these things never really
die unless they kill them
which is not really what i want yeah you
could take the pack rat i'd rather that
than the mantis
plus i want the item anyway
yeah let's go for this
actually i think that's a win anyway or
at least that's the end of that round i
don't know if he still plucks a thing
though he does not
he don't oh yeah wait i forgot about
that i don't really have a preparation
for that
ah
i sense a problem
well this is gonna hurt
oh wow yeah
oh my goodness
okay
oh boy
oh
oh oh
oh right well the damage is going to
carry over across it so that's actually
i think i'm still good i just need
another b to play oh i didn't even need
the b
let's see
let's try this
let's try that
blah blah blah blah blah easy easy easy
give me a challenge give me a challenge
i didn't think so i didn't think so you
big ugly brute with your ugly face and
your ugly fish
is any of these a bug
i do love unoriberous i do love a
neriburus i love an aeroborus the
aribrus is very nice the ariburus is a
delight oh yeah yeah
power
i don't really have a lot of power i
have the aurora boris now which would be
like the best bet if i draw that but the
chance of that is low uh well uh well
okay well technically there's two ants
so that would be a total of four this is
a bug this is a bug this is a bug and
the developers need to recognize this
there's two worker ants on the board
therefore they both have do attack power
and therefore it's a total of four they
don't have zero it does not say zero it
says ant and how many ants are there
there's two this should be a past
developer you have failed as a game
programmer how could you not think of
this scenario
and i will have your head on a fight i'm
just kidding
i'm so sorry i'm sorry i'm so sorry i
apologize i i apologize i apologize
sincerely i'm going to do an a frozen
impossible oh and i get another one i
don't need a squirrel squirrels are dumb
i need sudden gusts of flying that's
what i need
sudden bouts of uncontrollable lift
nice this is what we like to see this is
what we like to see
this is exactly what we like to see you
know why we like to see it because i win
i win
yeah maybe the bees aren't so bad maybe
the bees ain't so bad you know what i'm
saying
you know what i'm saying maybe they're
not so bad after all okay do i want the
do i want to put anything on something
else is that what i want put the pack on
a rubbers that might be good
and now my cards are good i don't want
to over complicate them uh i'm just
gonna well
nah that's fine
it's not my mess with it the recipe's
fine
uh
i'd rather have a two cost one ah three
might be good
grizzly i'll take it
uh mantis buff would be good
oh yeah
okay
run me i'm running back i'm running back
i'm running back i'm running back yeah
no none of that none of that none of
that
now i've got a [ __ ] beefy ass mantis
that gets to hit twice
oh yes
oh oh my god oh my god oh my god let's
just you know let's just get this over
with you know let's let's just get this
over with you know let's just get this
over with you know let's just uh get
this over with you know let's just get
it over with you know what i'm saying
you know what i'm saying i still didn't
get the opportunity to get no uh pelts
there's some pelts over there i guess
because i get i guess i don't know
unless there's a pelt radius there is a
pelt redeemer
later on
interesting
okay blood power and heart i do have a
lot of power cards come on give me the
power please don't be the ant thing
again come on oh you god damn it i have
so many powerful things you can't pull
one of those
[Music]
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] in
a million ways all right more power
please uh yes
please
no i'm not gonna do that i'm not gonna
do that this is just
an unbelievably powerful mantis and i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna risk it okay
not opposed to this
guys i'm not opposed to this it's not
perfect because i wish i could have like
you know
something a bit better but at least i'll
get unlimited bees
[Music]
oh god those can't die unless they get
hit that's probably a problem nah it's
fine what am i worried about it's fine
totally fine
oh is that a bee in my hand
grizz oh grisby
frisbee
oh
oops
frisbee
grisby time
i win
wish i had one with overkill but
whatever
all right i'm gonna go for the trapper
because i wanna i've got so many teeth i
might as well it could help me by the
end
cheaper prices oh
okay cool
thank you i'll take him goodbye hope
that doesn't mess up my whole process
might
it might do that
i could oh i made i just made the man so
powerful but if i could give that to her
boris that would
that would be nice how about i just give
some stink
stinky boars
[Music]
can't see your face boss time
easy
i wonder what would happen if i had so
many pelts that i took all of his cards
what if i had so many pelts that i just
took all of them
can i do that
i can do that i think i can do that
i actually think i might be able to do
that
interesting
[Music]
interesting
because i have a lot of pelts
interesting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
help
help
interesting
[Music]
interesting
[Music]
i don't think i'm gonna be able to get
the last frog but i think i still have
eight total pelts in my deck
so
you know
you know
i really do just like death by a
thousand cuts on this strategy here
i think i i might have
i might have eight pelts
i might actually
one two three four five six seven
ah
all right whatever man whatever man uh
you ain't going
killing killing killing
strange choices yeah you know i'm full
of them i'm full of strange choices i'm
kind of a strange dude
i'm just gonna get bees you know if you
guys if you don't mind i'm just go oh
he's a stinky he's a stinky
adder
i guess it would have flown over it
anyway all right fine then
fine then
i guess the only way to beat him is with
a grizzly
[Music]
i wonder if all my bees are going to be
pulled into orbit you know what i mean
i wonder if that wait does that can no i
don't keep these cards till the next one
it's just like temporary i don't think
these stay in my hand
do they
a long elk i think a long elk's cool all
right i have to win this one i have to
win this one i don't see why i wouldn't
i don't see why i wouldn't i should have
plenty of ability and i
if i'm not mistaken then my pelts did
get
bought
huh a cat don't need that anymore
another beehive don't really need that i
don't need any of these i really don't
need any of these i guess i'll take the
raven egg
oh okay i didn't keep them okay mantis
god
the god of mantis yes please thank you
all right let's do it
it's time where do you get a ring where
do you get the ring
whoa what is that
what is that 11 11 o'clock what
11
interesting
uh
i have plenty of rares now
usually wins me it
there we go
easy peasy
i do love magpie's eye but i also love
draw twice
ooh
i'll do draw twice
health i just got rid of all my pelts
ah
[Music]
oh oh oh oh
[Music]
goat's blood you will start battle with
a black goat on the board
that's nice
i'll take the black goat i guess
all right let's do it let's do it hey
bud how you doing pal
two boone's impressive i know
you like my boons hey you like my boons
big guy i'll show you all my boons okay
i have to win
another flame oh yeah
chidi style
[Music]
okay interesting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i knew you were gonna do that
that's okay
you can do whatever you want
not gonna do you any good
[Music]
oh [ __ ] it's on okay that's fine
[Music]
ow
whoa wait a minute hold on this is not
how this is going to go
let me tell you something straight up
this is not how this is gonna go because
i'm about to win this
for
sure
yep
[Music]
watch this nonsense good
ah mantis god that's not bad
it's not what i wanted
be
here
markimoo
here
mantis god
here
[Music]
nice there we go there we go there we go
that's what i was hoping for
[Music]
i think if he doesn't take this i've got
it
oh wait the flying defense i forgot
about that
now he's gonna take the raven
that's okay that's okay
[Music]
that's okay
oh i never actually saw it in my hand
oh
man i wish i had an aura boris
god damn it
okay yes death mantis i love that i do
love that that is great
super mantis
here
stunted wolf
here
[Music]
nice yes moon time baby
i still have a trick up my sleeve
uh-huh sure you do keep telling yourself
that will you dare attack the moon
god yes
absolutely yes where's my freaking
auroraburus
i should have gotten the magpie one that
that clearly was the superior choice
than double picking being able to get
exactly what i needed
mantis god is not in the right spot to
deal out all the damage it could but
mantis is
ow never mind
[Music]
where's my rubberis there you are you
[ __ ] oh but how do i get you on uh
marcus gotta go you know that's just how
it is
sorry bro marquemus got to go and the
moon just got stanked
then uh am i thinking
i put down bone elk
but i sacrifice bone elk to put down ant
ant and then and double ant
ah so close
weakening my moon with a fowler
absurd
yeah tell me about it
nice
shaba nice moon gone you lose do you
have any idea
the consequences of destroying an astral
body
no of course not
finish this
can do easy peasy
now it's picture time you're gonna love
the way you look
i guarantee it
the great scribe regaled you with his
stories he told you of a world long past
and of how he had conquered it of how
pure his intentions were
how
he only wished
enough
eat
your pure intentions don't matter to
this pure delicious meat
i am pleased i want to eat it
can't eat it
if you do not appreciate it we can move
on
i will not dwell on a rejected gift
okay
right through here
stand there
yeah you stand there too pal you stand
there too with one of these
and pop this bad boy who gave you that
you're absolutely great no oh
what
what is what is
oh
i got him
i uh thought i might
oh
i think i gotta go to the start screen
because now i think that was the new
game button
oh
[Music]
[Music]
in the beginning the world did not know
cards
that is
until the day the scribes arrived
each had their own method of inscription
to create carts
remora used her quill to inscribe the
epitaphs of the dead
unless she used his wildlife camera to
capture beasts
[Music]
po3 used a particle scanner to copy the
cpus of robots
and magnificus used his brush to paint
his wizard pupils
with the cards created the scribes had
solidified their power oh this isn't
this guy talking
until one day a challenger arrived to
replace one of the scribes
[Music]
i'm
freaking sorry
choose a starting deck to mark your
ambition mark
can i know what they're about your
ambition is to replace grimora and
become the scribe of the dead
your ambition is to replace leshi and
become the scribe of the beasts
your ambition is to replace po3 and
become the scribe of technology
your ambition is to replace magnificus
and become the scribe of magics
i don't know what else is here okay
i'll do
because i remember about magnificus
being important i guess
sure i don't know
what it means
what is this
that's what i said
i didn't just read that i said that
first
what is this
what in the world is happening
hi
i was just about to call it quits out
here
but now that there's a challenger in our
midst it's back to work for me
i should be able to get this bridge
fixed in nil
full disclosure it'll take me exactly as
long as it takes you to defeat one of
those scribes so we'll come back later
all right okay i'm gonna do that i guess
what
oh hi leshi 273 yeah
okay oh it's a fisherman
hi fisherman
no
no fish no pass
all right okay
what in the hell
you pried the chest open and found a
card pack inside he sees beastly card
pack oh what in the hell
no
no what is this
no what is this it's a whole new game
what is this
it's the same game but it's what is this
that dang hand got herself lost again
you think you're getting past think
again not till i get some proof my girls
all right
all right okay
watch out behind you dude
this is so
high lushy
uh no hard feelings right
two seven three
got it stinking pile of meat from the
safe excellent
just what i wanted oh yeah
okay
[Music]
i see why because the defender would
have gone to the snake one and then it
would have died
i
see excellent oh yeah i know what that
is
energy cells and all that muscle mage
and all that i don't
i don't know i don't know okay i don't
know i got it okay all right okay
gotcha
high
you wish to trade you don't perchance
have any powers
so except foils i don't want to give up
my foils that aurora boroughs is
incredible
oh wait no you have the aurora berries
and i want to i i would i
hm ah
wow
let me talk to leshi here
stop shaking
the only thing you have to fear is your
own inadequacy
behold me i am blessy
scribe of beasts
we share a desire for you to challenge
me
the first
[Music]
i know what you're thinking no this is
not my legendary camera not the one i
used to create beast cards
this one is a mere replica you may use
it to create photos of the beasts in
these woods
my subordinates the prospector the
angler and the trapper they each require
a photo before they will consider
battling you
return to me when they are all defeated
okay sure thing
else
[Music]
oh
oh
oh
all right you know guys this has gone
into a whole new world that i was not
prepared for there's more into this game
and i will get to it but i'm all out of
time for this episode
what the hell so thank you everybody so
much for watching i guess the plot
thickens even thicker than it was thick
so
thank you and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you